welcome back well I just hopefully we'd
together
figured out that correctly that the
total time in the air is this initial
velocity in this direction divided by 10
right that's our total time in the air
and now how far is the object going to
go well it's gonna go our displacement
our distance in this X direction is
going to be so let's see we could call
it distance in the X direction it's
going to be equal to VX this VX times
time times time in the air right times
this number and that's just because and
this is the average velocity cuz it's
not changing right this is a constant
because assuming we have no friction or
no air resistance air resistance is
really just a form of friction this the
horizontal component of this velocity is
going to stay the same the entire time
so the total distance traveled is going
to equal this number let me switch back
to that purple so you know what I'm
doing V sub I square root of 3 over 2
right that's this times the time in the
air well the time in the air is this
times V sub I over 10 so the distance
total traveled let's see this multiplies
V I squared times the square root of 3
all of that over 20 so now we know as a
function as a function of our initial
velocity in this direction how far is
this thing going to travel well we know
that we wanted to travel exactly 100
meters so we just set them equal to each
other we say 100 is equal to V I squared
times the square root of 3 over 20 and
then we can multiply both sides times
the inverse of this right we could
multiply both sides by 20 and divide by
the square root of 3 so we get V sub I
squared is equal to 20 times 100 is
2,000 divided by square root of 3 so
it's 2,000 times the square root of 3
and so our initial velocity we need to
shoot this thing at is going to be the
square root of this so initial velocity
is going to be the square root of 2,000
divided by the square root of 3 so let's
figure out what that number is just to
give us a a sense of whether this this
just feels right so let's take let me
take the square root of 3 first 3 square
root then let me inverse that times
2,000 that equals 11 54.7 and I can
squared this 33 point 9 8 so almost 34
meters per second so my initial velocity
has to be 33 point nine eight meters per
second for me so my initial velocity has
to be 33 point nine eight meters per
second to exactly hit this target 100
meters away I think I think that is that
is fairly cool and we could also do it
to figure out you know we could we could
do it backwards to figure out you know
if we know exactly what our velocity is
going to be right could maybe like a
slingshot always has the same velocity
and the only thing I can change is the
angle as long as we know our inverse
trigonometric functions we can actually
figure out the exact angle that we have
to aim to aim the slingshot or the
catapult or whatever to hit the target
so I don't want you to go out and you
know raise your own army and and
whatever else but but if you have to you
now know how to command artillery with
that I I will leave you and hopefully
you will not do something overly
destructive I'll see you soon